le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
mettre à l'honneur les seniors c'est
l'objectif de la semaine bleue
rencontres intergénérationnelles atelier
dîner dansant aux quatre coins de l'île
les ehpad et les centres communaux
d'action sociale se sont mobilisés pour
célébrer cet événement national
retour sur les actions menées à sainte
suzanne et à saint pierre pour fêter nos
ennemis
on va essayer de supporter
ses potes on non
échauffement en douceur pour les aînés
de sainte suzanne
ce matin ils ont investi le site du
bocage pour s'initier à plusieurs
activités sportives
une action organisée par le centre
communal d'action sociale à l'occasion
de la semaine bleue n'a voulu sur cinq
usages marquer le coup de la semaine
bleue et offrir aussi un bouquet
d'activités au fémur de sainte-suzanne
donc à la fois sur le volet information
des droits le volet rassemblement
convivialité le volet culturel
est ce que vous les sportifs lapin de
bluffer dédié une semaine en direction
des personnes à qui peut-on dans leur
vie ont contribué un petit peu à la vie
de la société
une contribution qui pour certains
continuent encore aujourd'hui
louis est très impliqué dans la vie
associative de la commune
adepte de marche nordique ils souhaitent
partager sa passion et son dynamisme
avec les autres seniors la semaine bleue
c'est une fois dans l'année et c'est la
semaine où on met les seniors en l'air
comme on dit quoi montrer que quand on
est senior
on n'est pas nominé des éclopés
quand on avance dans l'âge on recule pas
en capacité
on montre qu'on est encore bien présent
dans la vie locale et dans la vidéo
[Musique]
des gramounes qui ont bien affirmer leur
présence à saint-pierre également pour
fêter la semaine bleue l'ehpad de la
ravine blanche a organisé un défilé et
un dîner dansant pour les résidents
c'est l'un des rassemblements les plus
importants de l'année tous les angles il
ya une semaine consacrée aux personnes
âgées cette semaine se fait généralement
au mois d'octobre
juste avant la journée départementale
donc des personnes âgées c'est à ce
moment là qu'on se rend compte qu'il ya
encore des gramounes qui sont isolées et
que quand ils peuvent se rencontrer
comme ça le temps d'une semaine leur
épanouissement après s'en fout se fera
sentir
par rapport à cette semaine qu'ils ont
passé
rompre l isolement et rendre hommage à
une génération qui a elle-même chéri est
respecté ses ennemis moi même j'ai
soigné mon tonton rang c'est moi qui ai
occupé d'eux et
ça me faisait plaisir et était chez moi
on santé avec pour penser quand je ne
vieillira aussi un et après moi me vois
les personnes qu'elle est dans les
pattes dans les hôpitaux tout ça comme
ils savent avait atteint et napper les
valeureux nous apprend personne et c'est
ça le la joie n'est de jouer pour voir
un petit peu les vieux sur l'île le
nombre de personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie est en constante
augmentation
préserver leur cadre de vie est une
priorité pour le département
c'est vrai qu'à la réunion le lien
familial et paye encore privilégiée mais
comme je les dis s'attend quand même à
se fragiliser
étant donné que les enfants et les
petits enfants maintenant vont en
métropole c'est pour ça que le
département a mis en place également les
maisons d'accueillant familiaux qui vont
donc fleurir un petit peu partout sur
l'île dans les années à venir
le département est là justement pour
pallier à ça et faire en sorte que le
gramoune ne soit plus jamais isolée
[Musique]
lancée en 1951 la semaine bleue a pour
vocation de valoriser la place des aînés
dans la société
elle vise aussi à informer et
sensibiliser aux problématiques qu'ils
rencontrent au quotidien
à la réunion on estime que les personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans représenteront
26% de la population d'ici 2040 chef de
file de l'action sociale le département
développe de nombreuses actions dans le
but de préserver leurs bonnes conditions
de vie pour plus d'information ne
manquez pas la journée départementale
des personnes âgées le 28 octobre
prochain à l'acide et rd 400 au tampon
vous pouvez aussi vous rendre sur le
site du département au
www.desjardins.com 7 4 point fr lien
social accompagne le réunionnais pour la
mobilité
plutôt maeva 24 ans je viens de saint
benoît je suis actuellement sur
marseille je fais un bac pro accueil
avec la poste chargé d'accueil bras la
réunion marais de l'école à quinze nuits
bien sûr il m'a fait un ca fait
pâtissier glacier chocolatier confiseur
au ca fin samedi la balle et on le gros
mais l'aîné la réunion me ben amor la
réunion mais pas dans l'immédiat
l'âme il est près de tout ce moment-là
ce mono j'ai tissé de voyager voir
d'autres cultures aux riches ira moins
professionnellement moi jamais je
n'aurais cru d'être enfants s'ils
regardent aujourd'hui comme en mille est
bien ici me évolué et que ben le monde
est vaste
nous les qu'une petite île un point sur
la carte est faux nous représenter un
peu aussi dans les autres quartiers 2000
est là
[Musique]